i have six pages of questions
so let's try to get through as much as
we can quickly
if that's possible i'll do it so
if you could get the financing for any
project
this is an interesting question for you
because i would imagine most people want
to get in business with you right now
but
if you could get the financing for
anything what would you make and why
it dude this is going to sound so
terrible but i think i could make
anything i wanted to right now
and i i'm making the movies that i want
to make i wanted to finish the
story of guardians of the galaxy which
i'm doing i want to do the holiday
special which i'm doing
they asked me what i wanted to make a tv
show of it's peacemaker
and i always wanted to do the suicide
squad i was very uh jealous when
david got to do his movie so those are
the things i wanted to do there's
there's nothing
there's other things i think about all
the time a western i would love to do
sometimes i think about doing a musical
but
i've done the things that i want to do
and you know i'm really happy with my
choices you know i love this movie
and i loved the freedom that you had
working in the r rating
it was like a peak into your brain um
and i would imagine that it's going to
be tough i know you're going to do pg-13
for guardians
but if you made another comic book or
superhero movie
in the future do you see yourself going
back to pg-13
or do you think our rating is pretty
much your horizon
no i totally think i could do whatever i
think the story you know requires
like i would never do an r-rated
guardians of the galaxy it just wouldn't
be
what that show is it's about it's it's
it's for families and old people love it
and it just really is
it's more like a fairy tale and i think
it is completely that
is what it is you know suicide squad is
something very different than that you
know and the stakes are different and uh
you know all of that is different but if
i were to do say a shazam movie
you know which i'm not saying i'm going
to do shazam movie um
i don't think that should be you know
r-rated either i think that would be
if i did that it would be pg-13 if i did
deadpool it would be rated r so i mean
it just kind of depends on the project i
think everything is different the
audience you're speaking to is different
and i love pg-13 movies and i love
already movies i have any problem with
either
got it so essentially if you ever got
the keys to like a superman it would be
pg-13
yeah probably yes yeah um jumping into
suicide squad and i want to reiterate
again
how much i love this movie and how i
know fans are going to freak out for it
your script is so good who ruined
the most takes from laughing at the
dialogue you gave them
definitely margot ruined the most takes
because her stuff was flula
was he just made her stop he made her
laugh every two seconds
and she would not stop like flula made
everybody laugh constantly so uh that
was
that was really you know that's who it
was margot
what day of you after you turned in the
script to warner brothers
basically are you a little surprised
that warner brothers let you make this
movie because it's so
uh it's so not what they've been making
do you know what i mean
i i think i have a sort of blindness
about that sort of thing i wrote the
script the whole
the whole time thinking they would make
you know let me make it i mean
they you know they ask you know could
you make this pg-13 and i said no
um and i said you know you can make it
and take it with somebody else and they
can direct it and
you can do it pg-13 but if i'm going to
direct it i want it to be
r and they were like okay well that's
worth the trade-off for us
um and so they were they were great
about it what kind of notes does the
studio give you
um at this point in your career and
how often do you actually incorporate
them that's a great question
like they i give notes you know um
i get notes uh from uh from marvel and i
get notes from dc
um but no
they are always said you can take these
earlier you can do whatever you want
with these
if you want to take these notes you can
take them if you don't want to take
these notes you don't have to take them
it's never gotten anything beyond that
ever
um so uh so it's like they give notes uh
marvel gives more than dc does uh
to me but they're the same attitude of
like take what you want and leave the
rest
um and i i take a lot of them you know i
i
there's a lot of good ideas in there and
even if i don't take them
like one of the main things i do is i
try them especially
while i meditate i try them out to see
if they work
like sometimes somebody will say
something that i think is like
the worst idea it just seems so
distasteful for me
but i go ahead and try it out and every
once in a while i go
oh i'm really embarrassed because that
works incredibly well
maybe that happens maybe a quarter of
the time but 75 percent of the time i go
oh that's as bad as i thought it was but
it's worth it for the quarter of the
time that it works out that's a lot
so that's really my you know i'm very
open like on set
my assistant will say ah you know that
seemed fake
you know or something and i'll i'll
listen i'll listen to anybody um
i don't but at the end of the day it's
all me i mean nobody
you know any idea that i take in it's
because i choose to take it
not because i'm being told to do
something i'm curious
if your version if your suicide squad
takes place
in um an alt earth
or is it like what what universe does it
share with the current and i think
people want to know with the current dc
lineup does it take place in the henry
cavill superman
realm does it take place in or is it
undetermined
well i'm that's outside of my that's
that's outside of my
realm of knowledge but it is the dceu so
it's
whatever the dceu is today and with
aquaman and the flash and everything
else
that's where the suicide squad is so
that is that is what it is
uh i assume you learn from every project
that you make
um what did you learn making the suicide
squad
that you want to apply to future stuff i
just am much more confident as a
filmmaker than i used to be
and i can relax and i can you know
everything is is very planned out for me
so you know
people know i draw everything in the
movie before we shoot
so uh everything is done by the time we
get the set but i
was way looser with squat like i found
way more shots on set than i'd ever
found before
and i found that was a great strength in
my filmmaking to not be so locked in
like on the guardians movies
they're much more geometric so it's kind
of easier to plan them out
but at the same time i'll get on set and
i'll be like oh that shot looks good but
my brain goes no but you got to get the
day done
you got to get what you planned to get
done and i just go ahead and go with
what i had already planned
and i'm much looser and i'm learning to
be okay with that
of being looser on set allowing new
ideas to happen
find new stuff and follow my gut
instinct on set when things happen
and i think it's the reason why this
movie was so much more fun to make for
me than other films
you know i love asking this question how
long was your
early earlier cuts of the film versus
compared to the finished film
i think the first cut was
it was in the 240 range final one is
212.
when you say the 240 is that like an
assembly or is that a cut that you're
like this is pretty good
i think that was the assembly
i think that was the assembly was
probably 240. and then
probably i got it down to about in the
high 220s as my cut was probably what it
was
and then kind of just kept chipping away
from it from there there was one
big major theme section i cut out
uh near the very end of shooting
that near the end of editing that i was
really afraid to cut
um because there was so much cool stuff
in it but it definitely seemed like the
right cut
but people will definitely be able to
see it in the future because it's it's
great stuff and it's
mostly finished visual effects wise well
that's i wanted to know what was the
last thing you cut before picture
logging
that's what it was there's a whole
section with uh
with rat catcher and king shark and poke
it out man and thinker that i
that i caught that was pretty dynamite
stuff and
the hardest thing was some of peter
capaldi and
david das mountain's best acting
together
but it just was the wrong we take our
time a lot in the movie and i'm proud of
that
um but it was taking their time at the
wrong
point in the film so it was a good cut
it hurts
but that's how that's how moviemaking is
i'm assuming this is when they've
exited the bar and are together it's
right after they're outside the bar
yeah right when the guys when the guys
when
when when rick's flagging them or in the
the
armored vehicle completely um do you see
yourself
what for fan what can fans look forward
to on the eventual blu-ray
i think some really great uh you know
scenes that we cut out from the movie
you know
um there's a really great uh
uh scene with that's to jessie reyes's
solo which is in the movie
it's now seen in a moment you see this
moment where king shark is looking out
the window and he sees the young couple
kissing
and you realize in that moment hopefully
just how
he's not a part of this world and how he
longs to be a part of this world
and that actually was a much longer sort
of montage
um that is really beautiful and i really
like in and of itself
you know just again it was at the wrong
place in the movie did the mpaa
ask you to make any evidence no they
didn't i think
i think we got by at an r rating on
their first pastor
you know there was one thing i cut out
earlier
uh with one of the characters deaths
that was really gory
and i and i was like you know what it's
just a little too much
but again we might see it someday in
some form
one of the things is that you have this
ability to
write characters that are sometimes
terrible people
and make the audience root for them what
is that secret that you
the secret sauce that you're able to
make people care about these characters
well because i don't believe these
people are terrible at their core
you know i think someone like bloodshot
or harley you know i think they have
goodness to them
i think in a lot of ways this movie is a
story of bloodshot coming to terms with
his own vulnerability
and his own goodness which he has denied
his entire life
so i think it's really i i love i love a
bad character who
finds redemption like that's the thing i
dig more than anything else in stories
so that's part of it but there are other
characters in the movie that are pretty
freaking bad
you know i mean not to mention amanda
waller is not a great
person you know uh she's not great
thinker's not great suarez isn't great
they're pretty bad people
so i don't find the good in everything
there's thinker's very charming
he's funny but he's certainly not i
don't i don't see the good in them
myself
you know no completely you have two
amazing harley scenes in this movie that
fans are going to lose their [ __ ] over
did you feel any extra pressure because
this is such a beloved character
to so many people what is it like for
you writing scenes for harley
and is there extra pressure knowing that
these scenes are going to be
not dissected but kind of dissected
because of people's love of this
character
no i felt excited man i love the
character harley quinn i love pauldini's
original harley quinn
i think she's one of the most well
written comic book characters of all
time
and consistently well written not always
but a lot
and being able to you you know speak in
her voice and to write for her
was a privilege but i also felt
incredibly comfortable doing it
you know she isn't a james gunn
character because i didn't create her
in the same way i created rat catcher
too
you know or even king shark in this you
know some ways
but uh she is totally a james gun
character and then i
get her you know she isn't so different
from bolty and super
so it's like i i love i love her
character i love who she is and i felt
extremely comfortable making this the
most harley of all harleys
that have been on the movie screen there
are just such amazing shots of the
flowers and the birds
where did that idea come from to put
that in the movie
well i think in some ways it's something
that you know i always
you know i did a game a video game
called lollipop chainsaw
and i always loved the sort of uh you
know in that game
which i did with with suda in japan
um uh i always loved uh
the way that the hearts and hearts and
you know beautiful little things came
out of people mixed with blood and so
a lot of it goes back to that the
aesthetic of mixing
this horrible gore with harley's sort of
you know starry-eyed way of looking at
life and creating harley vision
basically
so uh that was something that came out
very early it was in the first
cut of the you know the first draft of
the script i think fans are going to
lose their [ __ ]
um one of the things that i love about
your script is that
every scene takes a left turn that
you're not expecting
and it it's i mean and it's hard and you
know this man when
i see a lot of movies and like when a
movie takes such left turns that you
don't see
coming it's so refreshing can you talk
about
where that how does that enter the
script phase
are in terms of are you writing those
kind of twists
like at the beginning when you're
writing the scene or is it sort of like
you know how does that how do those left
turns come into it
uh you know i was just really creatively
inspired with this
this movie and i can come up with a
bunch of bs about
how i came up with that stuff but the
truth is i was just really inspired
and as soon as i started writing the
script it just sort of lent itself to
that
with all of the twists and turns of
being able to surprise people and also
surprise me
you know harley has a big speech which i
guess you were alluding to earlier
and that big speech like i wrote before
i wrote the screenplay i wrote it down
like
on a piece of notepad or something so
it's like those things were just sort of
built in and baked in
and you know good you know all good
plots have plot twists
sometimes the plot twists are not so
noticeable in this movie they're really
noticeable because
they're the opposite of what you expect
but also in some ways frosty
there's a lot of big spectacle movies
that come out that are
you just know everything that's to
happen so it's kind of
to take people on a path other than what
they expect
when things have gotten a little bit
bland you know
i dude you're preaching to the choir the
biggest
the biggest issue i think with the movie
structure
that currently exists is that when you
are introduced to a character in the
first act
it's like okay spin the wheel it's one
of ten things
that this character is gonna be and it's
just a question of
what is it what of the 10 is it gonna be
which is why again uh and you know i
don't say this all the time why i loved
your script
because it kept [ __ ] hitting me over
the head in unexpected ways but
moving on because i'm running out of
time uh i i think the vfx on king shark
are just jaw-dropping and there's a shot
in the movie where he's
and you said it earlier where he's
looking outside the van
he sees the couple you see this
reflection on the windshield
and you see him behind the windshield
the the window
and you can he looks real and i sort of
can you sort of talk about getting king
shark
right on the screen because if those vfx
don't work that character is dead
it was really hard man it was really
hard
so you know you know i've done furry
characters
who used to be pretty hard but are much
easier now and i've done one characters
which are pretty easy
um but uh to be able to do the shark
skin was
really tough i mean we went through a
lot
of versions of trying to get shark skin
to look
real and it was hard and then
finally we get the shark skin looking as
good as we can and we built king shark
and i always knew he was like this bad
bod we designed them
but then he came out and there was just
something about his belly it was too
light
white it didn't look real he had too
much of packs and that looked
too you know mammalian you know and so
it really
so i actually broke him down and said we
have to break him apart and put him back
together again because
he's not working and luckily frame store
who developed
king shark and then also did a lot of
shots with king shark they both
worked together to create this character
that looked as
as real as he does now but it took a lot
of work and it took a lot of
moving forward and backtracking one step
forward two steps back over the design
i'm a huge fan of guy norris and you had
him as your second unit director on this
um i wanted to know if you could sort of
talk about the dynamic of you and guy
what you asked him to do and how much
does it hurt you to let
other people photograph your movies
um in this case it was easy because what
he photographed was the uh
the truck the car stuff outside of the
cars with the cars
flipping around and everything and we
paint i first i storyboarded it so it
starts with my storyboards
then guy takes it into his
post biz world and we turn it into post
biz
and then we decided exactly what it is
and with car stuff
you can very geometrically figure it out
guy and i are buddies
and i've known him since scoob he did
scooby in 2000 so
we've been we we've known each other a
long time i love his work i trust him
way more
than i trust other stunt coordinators
and um
and so it was pretty flawless working
together it's
it's hard at times it's a little bit
stuff different but
you know shooting cars really isn't my
thing like i've never
honestly i've never really done it
shooting people is different like
shooting action
people with action like i don't you know
that that's my thing like
i love doing that so i love taking guys
action sequences that we
develop together which he really
develops and does great work with
but then me being able to shoot it in
the way that's the most impactful like
that's
my thing but shooting cars and stuff
it's just it's just not my thing i think
a lot of people don't realize the
importance of
like obviously all the light is on you
and you deserve it
but i do think that there's so many
people that work on movies behind the
scenes that don't
get enough credit no yeah there's no
announcement guardians 2 i didn't use
the second unit director you know
because
i had such a terrible experience on
guardians 1 and just had to reshoot most
everything with the second unit
directors did
so on this one we do like what guy shot
was very
minimal you know it was that that scene
um
but uh but it's he's really important
but that's true about
i mean beth mickel our production
designer and julianna makovsky
are our costume designer those are
they're my like
those are fully my creative partners
henry brown the cinematographer
i've got those three people with me on
set all the time
unlike other like production designers
and costume designers
they're with me a lot and their input
is more important than anybody's input
to me because they
aesthetically understand the film and
they always have things to say about
you know stuff and i also don't i make
it so there's no clear divisions
between production design and props and
costume design
and cinematography it's all one thing
and so
we're we are really a team and one of
the great things about suicide squad
was having this team of individuals
together of me taking the best people
that i'd worked with on guardians 2
guardians 1
on guardians 3 which is shut down and
from you know even super
and before that you know i've been with
my editor now for fred raskin for a long
time
so these people are all my partners and
you're absolutely right they uh those
people
you know it all the glory goes to the
director all the glory goes to the
actors
but the production designer the
cinematographer the castro designer
they created this movie as much as
anybody and
it is a team effort absolutely yeah it
brings me to that i wanted to say uh i
always like giving
a like a shout out to an unsung hero so
besides the people you just mentioned
who's another person that you sort of
just want to give a shout out to
who just contributed a great deal to the
movie
well i'm a big fan of my my stunt folks
so ingrid who was uh
margo's you know stunned double um you
know
adam who was you know david desmond adam
hart was a david desmalking stunt double
spencer who was pope peace makers nate
it was
idris and stunt double those guys are so
great and they do a lot you know
um spencer who's peacemaker stunt double
has done the best stunts i've ever seen
in my life on the peacemaker tv show
by phone and he's beating the [ __ ] out
of his body
so those guys i love my stunt guys
they never get any you know attention
actors are always taking credit for [ __ ]
they do
and uh and i love those guys how hard is
it to find a stunt double for john cena
he's not a thin dude yeah he and dave we
have dave besties so we have real
problems with stunt doubling but
john's got his own guy spencer and
spencer goes he does every movie with
john
and he's a total [ __ ] filmmaker and a
part of the process
and he's my friend and i you know he's a
great guy something that i couldn't
believe is that
you built the jungle you built the beach
all the stuff was built on a sound stage
and it does not look like it's on a
soundstage
normally i noticed that wasn't on a
sound stage it was on a backlot so it
was outdoors so
the beer is too big for any sound stage
it's like the size of four football
fields
so it's enormous and uh i i
probably one of the biggest sets ever
made um
and it you know it has working turbines
that made waves happen
it has a beachfront it has a forest
of palm trees in atlanta beyond the
beachfront
and it was absolutely stunning and when
you were out there
hanging out at night it felt like you
were on the beach definitely the
greatest set i've ever been
what does warner brothers say to you or
your producers say to you
when you say so i think we're going to
have to build a beach
we're going to have to build this jungle
you know our
our executive producer and my you know
we're figuring out
really how can we do what we we want
that looks the best and is the most cost
effective
and that was really what it was you know
we knew that we needed to make a size we
couldn't make a little patch of beach
for that scene
it needed to be a big huge beach but
actually going and shooting on the beach
with rising and changing tides with you
know electricity nowhere to be found
with all of the things that could go
wrong that would have ended up being
you know really problematic and more
expensive i mean you can only shoot for
so long every day if you want
you know continuity to be the same with
where the beach where the tide is at
so it ended up being that was just the
most cost-effective way to do it
and also look the best yeah it's it's
fantastic um i'm just about out of time
and i have a few other questions so i'm
just going to i want to talk about the
post-credits scenes
was the final post-credit scene always
what that was or did it possibly get
added because
of the tv show it got added because of
the tv show
i didn't i didn't say i was gonna do the
tv show until
after um until after the movie was
basically finished
being caught so then i got asked to do
the tv show and then i
said i would do it and then when we
started shooting the tv show i shot the
post credits
was it always the other post credit
scene
uh earlier in the credits or was and did
you have any other ideas for post credit
scenes
that was always there was that
originally going to be at the very
end of the credits i think not i think i
was hoping i could put something else at
the very end of the credits
because i really like where that first
post-credit scene is now
i think it lays in nicely i think it's
it's just a part of the story
you know what i mean like the
post-credits of the post-credits scene
that's
it's not real it's really its own thing
setting up something else
but the first post-credits scene is a
part of the story in a way
it's sort of ironic that after all this
time
that that's what occurred i love ex
machina
and uh obviously because of oscar
dancing because it's
amazing um you had david
and john and i think someone else
dancing in the movie
did you give them directions on dancing
not
really i don't think i did i mean i
dealt a lot with
the dancing uh girls on stage
that was a choreographed routine um
i don't know if you noticed who those
dancers were but i didn't notice
actually
i can't no one has noticed yet it's
pretty big deal um
but anyway uh the other guys i i i you
know we talked about what it was like i
mean
you know in the script i think it said
john you know peacemaker is white boy
dancing
you know and that's what john came up
with what that thing he was doing and
you know and then i think daniella i i
may have told a little bit about her
doing that little twisty twirly thing
that she does
and then david desmalchin is just his
own thing you don't have to
he fits like he fits poke it at me like
a glove you don't need to tell him to do
anything
he he is uh so good in the movie
he is yeah yeah he's i mean listen made
it for him so i hope so
you know he's been my friend for a long
time and i wrote and i called i said hey
i gotta roll for you
he's like what is it i'm like he's
poking out man he's one of the leads of
this movie he's like
wow okay have a great day thank you so
much for your time
thanks rusty i'll talk to you soon